honoring a family that's lost so much a
week after seven members of the
zacharias family were killed in a mass
casualty crash in north las vegas clark
county leaders have come together to
honor them and speak out against
speeding on our roadways 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrough joins us with
more on tonight's event
yeah this caravan vigil which started
around 4 p.m has had a steady flow of
people and cars drive through as you can
see behind me and they have arrived here
at the crash site on cheyenne and
commerce drivers met up at the cheyenne
sports complex around 4pm and then drove
as a group to cheyenne and commerce
north las vegas mayor john lee along
with councilman isaac brown in
attendance trying to bring awareness to
speeding across the valley as this is a
chronic problem on our roadways people
could be seen wearing red shirts saying
stop speed accompanied by the north las
vegas fire and police department as of
wednesday morning the zacharias family
disabled their gofundme page after
reaching their goal of 300 thousand
dollars the mother and sister of the
victims her linda zacharias thanked the
community for their support we spoke to
a man who knows the family directly and
while he is giving the family space to
grieve he wanted to come out today and
show his support this way it's just so
hard
because we've seen the kids we've met
the kids and
what the family is going through right
now is just
there's no words there's no words to
explain but we just want to be here and
show our presence and support them that
we're here for them this isn't the only
vigil happening for the zacharias family
another one will be held tomorrow at the
mlk statue in north las vegas that's
happening from 4 30 to 6 p.m both vigils
are open to the public
[Music]
we will be out here all evening giving
you the latest details if you are headed
this way make sure to take it slow as
traffic is heavy reporting from shine in
commerce madison kimbrough live local
now